merci à tous 2500 ans je vais pas
remonter aussi loin mais on va en effet
partir dans l'histoire ce soir parce
qu'on avait pensé d'abord faire c'est de
vous inviter à faire un pas en arrière
pour que collectivement vous puissiez
faire un pas en avant
yann harlaut je suis docteur en histoire
spécialiste de la cathédrale de reims
sur lequel j'ai consacré une thèse
je suis consultant culturelle au sein du
cabinet trait d'union je fais au
quotidien des passerelles entre
l'histoire et les problématiques
d'entreprise l'histoire je pense que
tout le monde n'est peut-être pas à
l'aise avec l'histoire
ça semble un peu passéistes et ce soir
je vais essayer de vous montrer qu'il ya
des en effet dans des histoires passer
énormément de résonance et d'actualité
avec les problématiques d'aujourd'hui ce
que je vais faire c'est de créer des
analogies des liens entre vos
problématiques et d'autres
problématiques d'autres histoires de
co-création deux chroniques champenoise
que je choisis la première sera
consacrée la cathédrale de reims je vous
replonger sur le chantier de la
cathédrale de reims en douce aux 800 ans
le second sera consacré aux révoltes du
champagne et une révolte populaire
en 1911 deux chroniques de co-création
et vous allez le voir énormément de
petits messages qu'ils vont peut-être
faire écho faire résonance avec vous
tiens cela me fait penser à es6 jeu
pourquoi pas des petites questions
les vôtres je vous fait vivre l'histoire
et à vous de faire les résonances
première histoire donc le chantier de la
cathédrale de reims
il était une fois je me rends sur le
chantier de la cathédrale de reims et je
suis reçue par un compagnons tailleurs
de pierre restaurateurs sur le monument
depuis dix ans
tous les deux nous le connaissons bien
moi pour y avoir consacré une thèse du
pourrait avoir consacré une partie de sa
vie je suis dans l'intellectuel lui on
va dire sur le côté artisanal
je le dis très rapidement j'arrive et il
nous pose une question qu'est ce qu'une
cathédrale
je pense qu'il n'a peut-être pas compris
que j'avais fait une thèse sur le sujet
je réponds une église
le siège de l'évêque un monument
historique évidemment je suis historien
j'en fais un peu plus et lui il me dit
non moi je vois autre chose pour moi la
cathédrale c'est le h de l'homme les
tours symbolise l'idée mais l'idée n'est
rien si elle n'est pas connectée au
coeur à las rozas le deuxième niveau est
le troisième niveau
les portails cette capacité de tous de
se mettre en action
l'homme le projet l'idée le coeur les
jambes ils nous posent une deuxième
question je me démonte pas il me demande
ce qui et pour quoi ça consiste de
tailler la pierre
je lui dis mon extrait un bloc de pierre
et on va faire de manière à peut
ordonner un parallèle évident lui va
commencer continuer sur une parabole
nous sommes en douze sont sur le
chantier de la cathédrale de reims est
un homme vient visiter le chantier il
rencontre trois tailleur de pierre le
premier il s'adresse aux premiers d'une
demande qu'est ce qu'il fait lui répond
tu dois bien je taille la pierre c'est
comme ça que je gagne ma vie
il s'adresse au deuxième qui fait le
même geste
et ce deuxième lui dis moi je taille
beaucoup plus poliment la pierre
angulaire d'une arche
il s'adresse aux 3e et le troisième lui
réponds moi je suis tailleur de pierre
et je bâtis une cathédrale le même geste
je suis je fais je suis ce que je fais
je fais ce que je suis
et continue si ses hommes n'avaient pas
fait preuve d'audace n'avait pas été au
delà de ce qui était possible à l'époque
n'avait pas voulu élever une cathédrale
sans trop savoir comment il allait faire
sur 64 ans entreprendre quelque chose
que vous ne verrez pas fini le projet
n'aurait jamais abouti et pire le projet
n'aurait jamais été conservés le
monument serait resté vraiment
abandonnés par les générations suivantes
qu'est ce qui caractérise la création ou
la co création d'une cathédrale le roi
de france donne sa définition
il n'y aura jamais de construction noble
si l'architecte et ignoble eh oui
l'humain l'humain au coeur de cette
cathédrale et à mesure qu'il explique sa
perception des choses
nous arrivons à nous comprendre nous
visitons le monument nous admirons les
voûtes élevé à 38 m ces voûtes qui ont
quand même résisté à la première guerre
mondiale
il continue ses explications
nous entamons un dialogue est en effet
nous commençons véritablement à échanger
nous échangeons jusqu'au moment où nous
arrivons au niveau du transept et nous
allons regarder la rose nord du transept
et il va m'expliquer ce que c'est que ce
qu'est pour lui cette cathédrale
cette rose cette rose vous voyez bien
c'est un ensemble c'est une mosaïque de
verre chaque morceau de vitrail doit se
répondent les uns avec les autres mais
une rose c'est bien plus compliqué que
ça c'est à dire que vous avez des
forgerons qui font les bars le tiers les
maîtres verriers et bien entendu les
tailleurs de pierre larose est encerclé
dans un dans un cercle de pierres
si vous mettez votre expertise devant
celle de l'autre finalement voulu cacher
une partie de cette lumière
donc c'est rose symbolise cette
transversalité cette co création qui est
nécessaire pour qu'une oeuvre soient
créés et dure dans le temps
compagnon qui partagent le même pain
c'est à ce moment là que je comprends et
pour finir sur cette éco sur ces trois
principes du compagnonnage savoir savoir
être savoir faire je vous donnerai trois
citations comme je voulais dit que
j'espère qu'elles seront aequo avec vous
toute parole reçu que tu n'as pas
transmises et une parole volée vous
allez recevoir des paroles ce soir
transmettez ne pas s'en servir
ne pas se servir mais servir ça c'est
pour les bénévoles tlx je bâtis pour les
hommes
je bâtis avec les hommes et ce qui se
voit moins le mois en faisant cela je
bâtis des hommes co-création xiiie
siècle 1911 second chronique
un exemple de co-création que vous
connaissez bien que nous aurons
l'occasion de partager le champagne le
champagne le territoire de la champagne
mais n'a pas toujours été aussi
florissant que vous le connaissez
actuellement en 1911 il y a des
terribles désordre qui vont provoquer
l'intervention de plus de 20 mille
soldats
qu'est ce qui se passe depuis plus de 25
ans le phylloxéra ravage les vignes les
vignerons champenois essaye de lutter
contre la maladie mais là il va y avoir
de terribles récolte en 1909 et en 1910
en 1910 il n'y a quasiment aucune
production de raisin à tel point que un
vigneron va mettre toute sa récolte dans
une bouteille d'eau de vie une dame
madame hennequin qui possède un hectare
de vigne atteint cours va réussir à
faire une tarte
sauf que la production la vente du
champagne continue les débouchés
continue le champagne continue à se
vendre à s'exporter à très bon prix
les grandes maisons de négoce continue
donc à s'enrichir et en ces années de
vaches maigres il va y avoir une
incompréhension entre les producteurs et
les grandes maisons
une grande incompréhension pour les
grandes maisons il va falloir lutter au
maximum contre la fraude puisque en tant
que pénurie c'est plus simple de
s'approvisionner en vain d'autres
territoires français donc la tourelle
l'anjou donc ces grandes maisons
les petits producteurs veulent lutter
contre la faute créé la délimitation
l'appellation champagne
sauf que dans cette appellation
champagne on va véritablement avoir un
clivage chacun défend son propre clocher
pour créer cette première appellation on
va garder la marne et l'aide donc on va
exclure de la champagne viticole l'aube
évidemment incompréhension stupeur dans
l'aube qui réclame sa réintégration
pendant ce temps les marne et continue à
faire pression sur l'état qui tâtonne
avant ce recul en avril 1911
l'incompréhension est telle que les
vignerons donnent l'assaut et pire un
certain nombre de maisons de négoce
accusés d'être des fraudeurs
l'incompréhension vous voyez abouti à
une révolte populaire l'état règle le
problème des pêches quinze mille soldats
dans la marne 5000 dans l'aube à à tel
point que pour rentrer à reims il faut à
partir de 5 km aux alentours présenter
ses papiers quatre régiments de soldats
ont pris position à la ville de reims
c'est véritablement une sorte de
couvre-feu qui est instaurée
parallèlement les les aubois manifeste
gisait en ordre plus ou moins vous voyez
ventres affamés ils essayent de défendre
leurs positions
on brûle en place publique un certain
nombre d'entre toutes les fiches
d'imposition vous voyez il ya une
défiance vis-à-vis de l'état crise
défiance vis-à-vis de l'état pauvre
république française
ta devise f le camp fous l'camp
voyez il ya une certaine défiance qui va
aboutir finalement à se repositionner à
réfléchir à une nouvelle forme de co
création commune les grandes maisons
vont défendre l'excellence du champagne
est véritablement l'art de co-créer
c'est-à-dire de death se défendre contre
eux mais les mauvaises appellation ou la
concurrence la fraude les petits
producteurs eux vont se dire il faut
maintenant reprendre en main notre
produit donc envie d'avoir un certain
nombre de petits producteurs qui vont
commencer soit ce groupement coopératif
pour produire leur propre champagne soit
à créer eux mêmes leur champagne c'est
le cas maintenant actuelle vous avez
bien compris
fallait-il tout casser pour en arriver
là
finalement fallait-il une révolte
changer la donne pour réussir aboutir à
ce qu'est le champagne actuellement
restons sur les chiffres actuellement
une centaine de grandes maisons
possèdent un peu près vent deux tiers
des bouteilles de champagne pour les
trois quarts du chiffre d'affaires
inexistant au début du 20e siècle les
petits producteurs ou coopératives ont
dès lors un quart du chiffre d'affaires
global donc il ya une nouvelle
répartition et une nouvelle co création
qui permet finalement à ce qu'il y avait
30 bouteilles 30 millions de bouteilles
produites en 1910 300 millions
actuellement la défense a abouti à
l'excellence d'un produit et une
démocratisation et depuis on va dire
qu'entre les différents acteurs de la
filière champagne la concorde existe
ce que je voulais finir sur ces deux
exemples de co-création c'est de se dire
que il faut pas hésiter à oser oser
faire preuve d'audace
comment mais d'abord par une certaine
concorde co-créé comme les compagnons
bâtisseurs des cathédrales comme les
vignerons champenois
il faut d'une certaine manière réussir à
trouver une nouvelle voie
n'hésitez pas à essayer de trouver un
modèle plus harmonieux n'hésitez pas à
oser faire les choses différemment
vous voyez que par le passé c'était
possible celle l'est tout autant
actuellement l'historien est un passeur
d'histoires donc ce soir j'espère vous
avoir fait passer deux histoires
j'espère que ces deux histoires vous ont
plu d'une certaine manière et vous
permettront de voir et doser ses hommes
ont créé ont réussi quelque chose sur
lesquels maintenant nous vivons mais
d'autres modèles sont encore possibles
il faut savoir faire le lien entre passé
présent et créez votre futur merci et
puis bonne plonger dans le 3.0